jack you're looking fit oh thank you
yeah you're looking trim well thank you
you're looking like you're in player
shape player ready
almost i got about i already lost like
35 pounds i wanna lose about 20 more
pounds and i'll be in my 2000
championship weight i'll let you do the
math and how much i weigh
please don't make me do the math you
should know that by now i can't do math
i feel like you look almost trimmer
ready for this is it my hot take on the
day
you kind of look trimmer than you did in
like 2002 aren't you like
you look really good i got about 15
pounds to go for that
so i like to i like to work in phases uh
so you know the first the first one was
just to eat right face slim down
the second phase was to lift weights
phase try to get you up and the third
phase gonna be cardio cardio cardio
running running running
i haven't ran in like 10 years i tried
to jog the other day
i felt like i never ran into my life so
i'm what i gotta
i'm doing what's known as a minute
minute jog
so i'll walk for a minute run for a
minute one for me i'm gonna do that the
first week and then the second week is
gonna be
walk for a minute run for two minutes
and then you know just try to bring it
up
well dion sanders always said i've never
seen a fat
runner i've seen a lot of fats i've
never seen a fat sprinter
i've seen a lot of fat runners but i've
never seen a fat sprinter
yeah that's why that's what i do i do a
sprinting workout which by the way
i haven't done lately but you know hey
um you don't need to do anything you're
a supermodel
oh shaquille rich eisen is the luckiest
man in the world he's
he's old
[Laughter]
rich is old and he's married to a 22
year old super
model sports illustrated supermodel rich
is the luckiest man in the world
it really is amazing that i'm only 22
and yet i covered you playing
21 years ago it's amazing how i've aged
uh and the one time you've ever been mad
at me remember i i
called you when we were talking about
one of these things and i said yeah you
look like you
you lost somebody remember when you used
to have a bit of a gut you're like i
never had a gut
i never did it was just that the jersey
was made a little too big
we were just talking before the break
about the the
the big men that are out there right now
and how they're all shooting threes
did you ever take a three-pointer
think i'm one out of 20 for a
three-pointer but it wasn't it was like
a it was like the end of the
end of the quarter desperation shot i
would never step into a three
uh but you know what what makes me happy
about the big guys this year is that
uh in the last 20 years you haven't
really had any big guys in the mvp talk
now you got two guys that could
potentially be mvp
and jokic and joel embiid so i'm happy
about that
yeah we saw those games on tnt i think
chris webber was calling one of them and
watching zion williamson because he's 20
years old and i always say that he's the
only player out there
out there right now that reminds me of
you at all
but he's out there and he's working on
his threes and it's amazing
to me you sat here with me a couple
years ago or maybe you called in and you
were said
you said three years ago i predict that
big man makes a comeback
and you were right yeah they're starting
to play big
especially zion i like the way he plays
he plays bowley ball
you know this league has been a copycat
league for so long but
you know when you're a great player you
don't do what everybody else is doing
you make them adjust to you
so i laugh when people say i could never
play in this era that makes no sense to
me i would make people adjust to me i'm
not shooting no threes
every time you shoot three and miss i'm
running right to the middle lane and
staying and then you're gonna have to
double and triple like they always did
so
you know i i just i just like big guys
to be big and you know just use their
size just because
the game says you can shoot three points
don't mean you have to go out there and
shoot three points
who's your favorite guy out there right
now oh steph curry is my favorite guy
because i've i've seen the best
played against the best uh beat the best
and i've never seen anybody do what
steph curry can do that's why he's my
favorite player
like when i sit up there like i'm you
know people think i'm really hard on the
guys but
look i've seen a lot if you're not close
or above to what i've seen
i don't really get excited so but steph
curry
has always excited me what is it about
him
because every time i think he's gonna
miss that crazy looking shot he throws
up
he makes it and if you look at him he's
not he still looks like a little baby
you know he's not the guy with the big
muscles or a guy that could jump really
hot
he wasn't the guy that was highly highly
touted after
after high school or college and he just
came and
uh became the mvp of the league has
three rings
his team done it the right way through
hard work and perseverance
you gotta respect that susie schuster
shaquille o'neal here on the rich eisen
show
you know you talked about how you talk
to players obviously you talked to
donovan mitchell directly after a game
the other night and kind of gave him a
piece of your mind
how do you use that and what's going on
with you and donovan by the way i'm sure
i'm curious to hear if you guys have
talked after that
you didn't see what i did i saw what you
did exactly
so did it work last time i did it when i
was in l.a
i was there for it yes i remember well
okay so so as a leader sometimes you
gotta
ruffle some feathers see a lot of people
think this person with me it's never
personal with me
i got too much going on to make it
personal but
hey uh you know we're we're paid to be
objective and
it's my opinion that he wasn't at that
level but he's playing at that level now
so
you welcome you know this is what you do
as a locker room leader this is what you
do as
a leader you you know you see who you
could talk to a certain way
phil would always talk to us like that
but he couldn't talk to all the guys
like that
so i really didn't know donovan so i
probably could have worded
you know words a little different but
i was just testing out you know to see
what he was but i
we have we have mutual friends so i know
who he is i know about his character i
know he's a tough kid so
i knew he would be able to take it and
he's playing well and utah is playing
well and
i wish him very well but again i know
what i'm doing you may not know what i'm
doing but i always know what i'm doing
yes i'm well aware and you're right that
is how phil jackson worked
he wanted his leaders on the team to
communicate with the other guys on the
team
i think that's one of the reasons why he
and kobe had that bristly relationship
at times because kobe wanted to be the
leader on the team you were the leader
on the team
and i do know and i do remember when you
did use the media because often times
would be with an
interview with me and we would talk
about kobe
and you would try to get your point
across and it was difficult
and it would get him so mad that he come
in the next game and have a fabulous
game so my plan always works
they they they don't call me dr
shakavacco for nothing
a mad scientist susie i'm a mad
scientist oh you're something all right
that you're something right susie
schuster here with shaquille o'neal i
called you my seven foot one security
blanket because i don't like to do a
show without you is that strange
uh we have good chemistry we we we've uh
done a lot
you've you've taught me a lot you've
been a good friend
well thank you thanks to cynthia as well
hey uh i'm curious about
all the guys that are out there if you
could pick a couple guys to play with
who would be on your team
steph curry clay thompson
[Music]
zion williamson and lebron
and lebron yes
it's a strange thing to ask because
people would say well why would you ask
why but why
i'm just curious okay
you're gonna have to double me and
steph and clay gonna be wide open right
lebron's gonna get that thing take it
off the glass and go full speed
he's gonna have three guys that's gonna
be in front of him i'll trail
i'm i'm a trail gonna be in nobody's way
so he's gonna have two guys on the wing
and steph and clay
and you're gonna have another guy that's
gonna tear the rim off and zion
williamson
that's my five right there and nobody's
beating us
shaq i'm curious another question or two
for you with shaquille o'neal here on
the rich eisen show
it's a strange season and it's hard to
say to you later on like
right now can you please predict the
finals because
pandemic play makes everything strange
as we just see the second half of the
season launched what are your
predictions for the playoffs and for the
first i would like to
i would like to see brooklyn
versus l.a now just put
let me go back in the eastern conference
finals i would like to see
brooklyn versus philly okay
in the western conference finals i would
like to see la versus the clippers or la
versus utah
and then uh in the perfect world i would
like to see
la versus brooklyn all the stars
three stars versus two stars and see who
fans are the best
we just hung up with dog rivers a couple
minutes ago and we were talking to him
about
joel embiid and ben simmons and how
they're playing together
how has doc been so successful so far in
philadelphia
it's all about his resume doc has a
resume that you must and you will
respect
and as a player you saw when phil came
in whatever phil said it was gold
because we knew it was going because
every time we got swept by utah san
antonio
we'd be watching him in the finals so
it's obvious he knew what he's talking
about it's obvious doc knows what he's
talking about
and he probably just told joe like hey
joe i don't mind you shooting some
threes but
i think you need to play big and you
know play inside
joe's been playing like he looks good
ben's been you know doing this thing
tobias harris is the is the superstar of
the team so far like he's the one that's
been you know really
stepping his game up and i hope his
injury is not
not uh you know that bad of an injury
but you know doc got the guys playing
well
and again it's all about resume and
respect they know that doc
rivers knows and understands what he's
talking about and it's so different than
his experience in l.a with paul george
and with kawhi leonard and i think you
hit the nail on the head also too
young players will absorb more because
when you guys when you guys were there
in 2000 phil came in
it there were some veterans i mean ron
harper came we had some veterans that
came but
you guys were a group that was willing
to listen you have to be willing to be
coached in order to accept we knew we
were good but we knew we weren't good
enough
like we always had great rental season
big big games already
but every time we got to playoff versus
utah san antonio
we get swept so we're like hey
we ain't that good so you know phil come
in and
he taught us and he taught us how to
think and tell us how to play
everything you know just you know turned
around so
i know ben and joel they they they want
to win
they want to do well so you know like
you said you have to be
willing and eager to listen shaquille
o'neal here on the rich eisen show i'm
susie schuster
in for rich eisen uh we talked also in
the show and we've talked the last two
days kyrie irving has led the chorus of
players calling for kobe bryant to
replace
jerry west as the logo what are your
thoughts on that shaquille
i mean look everybody has his opinion
that's his opinion
look i love wes i love mr kobe
whatever the powers to be are going to
do they are going to do
i don't i'm not going to say do this do
that
because you can say the same thing for
magic say the same thing for larry bird
say the same thing for kareem
abdul-jabbar a lot of guys you could
change the logo to
and uh but look you know mr west is my
guy and kobe is my guy
i wouldn't be mad at either either one
of those choices
but uh you know adam silver he's
he's been remarkable he's been brilliant
he's been
fair so he will always do the right
thing so when he addresses it then i
will address it
what haven't you done that you want to
do you just started a media company
you shill for so many different products
you're
wrestling which by the way don't do that
don't get hurt
i mean i don't we can talk about
wrestling in a minute but what
haven't you done that you want to do
shaquille i want to i want to sky dive
with you and rich
at the same time not happening not
happening what else do you want to do
that's why not i'm not so big out of a
plane
first of all shaquille jews don't jump
out of planes
i'm not allowed to say that so i'm just
glad you said it
i said it
let me be the one to say on behalf of
jews everywhere we don't jump out of
planes
because we're not oh okay let's all do
tandem jumps we'll have like
professionals on top of us to make sure
we land safely
there's no chance i'm doing that next
what else haven't you done that you want
to do
that's probably it might be
no no actually you know what comedy i
know he's a fan
the man that wears a rocket man suit
contact me i want to buy one of those
rocket suits
you know who i'm talking about oh
have you ever seen them yes yes so
whoever you are mr rocket man this is
shaquille o'neal need you to contact me
i will keep your identity secret but i
need one of those rocket suits
so contact us at 844 204 rich if you are
a rocket man and you have that suit is
that what you're saying
yes if you have that suit contact me
contact me at the rich eisen show
because i want to because i want to fly
just one time would it need to be custom
made
there's no chance that guy is seven one
three forty
yeah but yeah but if it lifts them off
the ground a hundred feet it could
probably take me ten feet
all you have to do is go to cabo and
have some guy can't you know put a lot
of things on your uh
no i want his suit all right
we'll try to reach out to rocketman see
if we can find him what about wrestling
shaquille what are you
doing what's happening you and jade
cargill and who's it cody rhodes and a
woman who's named red velvet i'm just
saying
well well cody challenged me you know i
don't back down from a challenge he just
kept challenging me i told him melanie
kept challenging me so
now i'm gonna have to uh touch him up on
march 3rd
okay on tnt shaquille i
challenge you to do a tv show with me i
challenge you
can i get a tv show with you now is that
how it works uh
yes i mean you heard it here first i
mean
i'm challenging you to a television show
with me shaquille
you know we can call it susie and the
diesel yeah
and you can yeah i think that's i'd
watch it hey peacock if you're paying
attention you know
i i i'm just saying i think susie and
the diesel is
is the way to put it if i could just
kazam it to happening
i would kazam went into happening and tj
jefferson wore his hair up in a kazam
top knot today just so you know
with all do uh with all due respect he
wore the top knot for you today
if you um you're welcome um are you a
james bond guy
of course i like all the bombs sean
connery was my favorite though
actually no i'm gonna go without roger
moore no roger wallace was nice because
he was smooth
right yeah yeah they were very smooth
how do you feel about idris elba as uh
the next james bond
that work for you i would actually like
that i love israel's albert he's a
fabulous actor
uh he's a beautiful beautiful human
being beautiful man i always ask my
female friends who's your man
question his name always comes up
because they're not crazy
that's why because they're not crazy
i don't have any man crushes shaquille
i'm married to a lovely guy
good answer you are so good that's good
right
because i know he's listening there i
don't need a man crush
i just i i know well i i try to keep up
with you
they are rebooting superman we found
that out today are you gonna put your
name in there for uh superman you do
have that you got the jersey
i'm not that good but they wanted to
play one of the villains i was and uh
whose name is coming up
listen the last guy that plays superman
what's his name christopher reeve
no henry cavill henry cavill
yeah yes i met him at the beverage hills
hotel and he he grabbed me from
the back he squeezed my shoulder when i
tell you this dude was so strong and so
fit
i was like damn hey superman he was like
hey shaq how are you
he was a he was a nice fella uh i don't
mind if he continues to play superman
yeah he's been on the rich eisen show
i'm not gonna lie rich posted a picture
of him
standing next to henry cavill and he
said um that's henry cavill next to the
handsome guy and i was like what
and i literally thought can i can is it
wrong if i cropped my husband out of
this picture
that's wrong right shaquille yeah that
is wrong
that's called shaquille o'neal you
always come through for me thank you so
much for calling in
no problem tell the lovely children i
say hello and tell you a beautiful
awesome husband i said hello
love you buddy that is shaquille o'neal
always comes through
my seven foot one security blanket hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here